first of all let's talk about baby zara
how is it
how's it being a new dad it's amazing
it's definitely
a whole new experience adjusting to
fatherhood and
i enjoy every minute of it you and rhoda
together
how was that how was your relationship
if you could describe it
with her it's perfect is it really
perfect because
that's a huge statement absolutely yeah
it's perfect
like uh we both kind of just bounce off
each other
everything about our relationship just
flows and
there's not one thing i can say that i
would change
you've been through so much and we've
watched what you've been through
but now you're describing that you're in
a relationship that's perfect you have
your beautiful baby girl
how would you describe this time i feel
like
i've definitely been blessed um
you know when i was going through all of
my troubles and uh
when i was locked up and you know going
through all of the uh
situation that i was going through in my
past um
i definitely didn't foresee this in my
future
yeah and now just going through it and
uh being here in the present time it's
like
it's it's almost like living a dream
that gives me chills
um because i look in the comments
section of you know the interviews
you've done or your recent videos
and people are so inspired knowing that
you can be down and out at your
the worst you know hit the bottom but
you can come back and have something you
never even expected to have
how do you feel when you see the
reactions to your glow up it's
definitely a great feeling knowing that
i'm able to
change at least a little bit in
somebody's life yeah
what do you think attributed to that
change because i believe that
you have to change on the inside really
for your outside
to reflect you know something better so
what do you attribute
the the blessings to um
i definitely think that it's a mindset
you know um
being in uh i would say solitary
confinement for a little bit you kind of
tend to think a lot you really
you get the opportunity to read a lot of
books and uh
kind of change your mindset of things
and i kind of got the uh
the the not the hints but the taste
of success a little bit when i was able
to change my mindset
to change my personal appearance like
with
literally a a small
um seed per se
like i read a book and with
what i learned from this book it kind of
gave me the motivation to change myself
you know i figured awaken the giant
within or something like that okay yeah
i've read that book
maybe three or four times and
no no joke this book inspired me
and i kind of carried that out with me
you know if there was one thing that i
could say i took with me
is um that change of mindset
yeah and it affected your appearance as
well
right so did you consciously lose weight
or was that just the effects of
you know being in prison and just the
food and all of that
i consciously did it i mean in prison
there
you could you have access to um
purchasing food and still maintaining
the outside weight and there's people
that never change
or they get bigger in there um it
definitely has to be a mindset within
you know it has to be something that you
choose to do
and um i i fail honestly
at the very beginning when i was going
through it i felt hopeless i felt
powerless
and i felt like i couldn't do anything
to
reflect my my outside environment um
and it wasn't until going through all of
this that
i was able to see that
it shouldn't be i shouldn't try to
control what's going on out on the
outside but
try to change what was within and that
little small
change sparked everything that that is
happening now wow
so so do you look at that time in prison
as
i guess a blessing now a growth
definitely a growth
it was able to change me to um
a better person when i was in there i
lost uh 125
128 i i came out i went in at
3 18 and i came out at 185
wow well a big part of you know weight
loss is
maintaining that weight loss so what
have you done to keep it off
well right now i kind of gained a little
bit of uh daddy weight
but um uh i think since i've been out i
gained like 35 pounds
but i still feel healthy it's not like
overly
well i was 185 that i felt like really
really skinny
but um i still feel healthy um
i i don't feel like i've overdone it i
guess it's just kind of maintaining a
healthy diet
really um that's that's where what it
really comes down to
like weight loss comes down to like 95
diet
and um 5 in the gym
so true that's so true okay so we talked
about all the good stuff now we gotta
rewind a little bit because i know
this is 90 days fans want to talk about
um anfisa
so when's the last time you spoke to her
have you all spoken
recently um the last time i was on a
well
i haven't spoken to her directly but the
last time i heard her voice
was um the hearing for the divorce
like for the final paperwork to go
through um
she was on the other line when the court
was going
through its proceedings and uh they
finalized everything that was the last i
heard from
having her how do you feel when you even
hear her voice like does it bring up any
old
emotions i really don't have any hate or
like you know
or uh badge feelings
if what's so say because whatever i went
through
has given me what i have learned
i love that and i was just about to ask
you do you have any regrets but
i think you just made a beautiful point
there yeah i don't i don't have any
regrets
yeah well some fans believe that
superficiality
kept you in that relationship with her
just being focused on looks and
the wrong things when it comes to
attracting your mate do you think that's
true
and if so has your mindset changed when
it comes to that
i do think it's true but at the same
time i was at a point in my life
when i was going through other
situations
uh business problems um just the whole
my mindset wasn't where it was supposed
to be and i got entrapped
in what i thought was love and um
my decisions weren't
the best of you know my my current
circumstance so i
i felt like i was chasing love to
replace
or replenish what i was missing out on
you know the rest of myself
where i should have just changed myself
right
right they say you can't get love if you
can't give it to yourself exactly
yeah all that stuff sounds so cliche but
it's so true
how did it feel to get her tattoo
removed i know you showed that off on
instagram
that felt like the last piece of
my last or that relationship that i
needed to complete
i just felt like or i felt like that was
um
kind of the last little bit of weight
off my shoulders
wow you mentioned that you
had the wrong idea of love when it comes
to her
how has rhoda changed your mindset when
it comes to that what has she taught you
about love
she didn't teach me about love
but my mindset of love
with rhoda is what i pictured
in my password in my what i was chasing
it was like not what i was chasing but
what i was
desiring you know i i desired to feel
loved from
from somebody else as much as i love the
person
yeah so rhoda you feel like it's an
equal exchange there
absolutely i'm so happy for you
that's so nice the 90-day universe
continues to expand
it seems like we get a new show every
every other week
do you see yourself coming back to the
franchise at all or even
just coming back to reality tv in
general i would say that if the
opportunity
was right for me i would be open to it
but at the time being i think the best
platform for
me and my relationship my family is
probably gonna be youtube
um that way we have control over our
own content and um there's no pressure
from
any outside sources our plans with the
channel was to kind of document
our are raising zara sort of so she can
kind of go back to the channel reflect
on you know past memories and hopefully
the audience enjoys that like she will
and um that's all pretty much i have to
say
um i don't necessarily want to say that
i'm doing it
for um an audience it's more of
for our family and maybe we can share
that with the world and maybe inspire
others to
um kind of necessarily feed off of our
[Music]
energy